Na gut, aber wäre vielleicht auch mal eine interessante Option. Dani Mo, was würdest du reinschreiben bei deiner Software? Ich bin da ehrlich gesagt nicht so ganz mit mir selber im Reinen bei dieser ganzen Geschichte, weil, also klar, ich könnte mir irgendwie schon vorstellen, so was da reinzuschreiben. Ich mache meistens GPL-Software. Ich habe schon erklärt, wo die juristischen Hürden da liegen. Aber jetzt rein so von dem, was ich denke, was sinnvoll wäre. So eine Abstufung, auch wenn ich es dem Andreas jetzt wegnehme, wie Andreas das vorgeschlagen hat, klingt erst mal wie ein sehr sinnvoller Ansatz. Also zu sagen, je nachdem, was jemand mit seinem Gewissen vereinbaren kann, wenn du mich jetzt fragst, welche dieser Abstufungen ich persönlich nehmen würde. Darum geht es genau. Na gut, dann werde ich mal Farbe bekennen. Ich würde wahrscheinlich dann tatsächlich die maximale Ausbaustufe nehmen wollen. Also keine Geheimdienste, kein Militär, keine Polizei.
Ja.
Das ist interessant. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass die Leute nicht anfragen können. Und wenn die Polizei mir einen Grund nennt für ein spezielles Projekt, das ist ja bei Creative Commons auch so. Da steht irgendwie Non-Commercial News, aber das heißt ja nicht, dass es nicht kommerziell verwenden ist, sondern dass die Leute erst mal bei mir anzutanzen haben und mir erklären müssen, warum ich das total cool finden soll, dass sie meine Software in genau diesem Projekt hier zu verwenden sollen. Und wenn das jetzt irgendwie für einen Search-and-Rescue-Helikopter ist, der irgendwie garantiert nichts anderes machen kann als Search-and-Rescue, dann ist das völlig okay für mich.
Ich finde die Frage schwierig. Und zwar insbesondere deswegen, weil das ist ein ähnliches Ding wie die GPL versus BSD-License-Debatte, wo wenn man sagt, naja, eigentlich glaubt man an Urheberrechte ja sowieso nicht so richtig, dann plötzlich aber anfängt, mithilfe von Urheberrechten Dinge durchzusetzen, das ist halt schon Widerspruch. Also ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob ich nicht einfach weiter an bestimmte Software irgendwie heranschreibe hier, all rights reversed, mach doch was ihr wollt damit. Auf der anderen Seite kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass ich nicht will, dass mit meiner Software, keine Ahnung, Bomben gebaut werden, Leute erschossen werden und es ist, glaube ich, eine Einzelfallentscheidung. Und dann müssen wir erstmal gucken, was es gibt.
Wie pro Software meinst du?
Ja, schon pro Software.
Aber wäre dann nicht mein Vorschlag letztendlich auch zielführend dafür? Abgesehen davon, dass du dich nicht vielleicht mit jeder Anfrage auseinandersetzen magst.
Ja, nee, die fragen mich im Zweifelsfall gar nicht. Also da kommt so ein bisschen das philosophische Problem rein.
Naja, wir machen das ja alles. Also zumindest, ich habe jetzt mal eine Antwort unter der Promesse gegeben, dass das, was THS gerade in seinem Interview vorgeschlagen hat, das Ziel ist nämlich, dass man den Leuten wenigstens dann auf die Finger hauen kann, wenn es rauskommt. Es bleibt schwierig. Aber bei dieser ganzen Hacking-Nummer gab es da noch eine andere Sache. Und da gibt es schon ein Regelwerk, da wird vom sogenannten Wassenaher-Abkommen gesprochen. Was ist das und inwiefern kann das sowas regeln?
Das ist ein ganz spannender Punkt, weil eine weitere wichtige Komponente, außer in Anführungszeichen normalen Software-Komponenten, die in der Hacking-Team-Software und in anderen Spionage-Softwaren drin ist, ist ja der, wie komme ich in die Rechner rein? Also die sogenannten Exploits, die dafür sorgen, dass mein Angreifercode ausgeführt wird auf dem Zielsystem, dem Zielrechner, dem Zielmobiltelefon. Und da kommen die sogenannten All-Days ins Spiel. Das heißt, Sicherheitslücken, die unbekannt sind, Exploits dafür, möglicherweise auch Exploits für bekannte Sicherheitslücken.
Also dann muss man vielleicht noch dazu sagen, Exploits, das heißt, es gibt immer Sicherheitslücken, das heißt so eine theoretische Möglichkeit, wie man in ein System einbrechen kann. Und Exploits ist dann die konkrete praktische Umsetzung, die auch wirklich funktioniert.
Genau, und das Wassener Abkommen ist also ein Abkommen, das die Exportrestriktion für sogenannte Dual-Use-Goods regelt, also für Technologie, die möglicherweise auch zum Waffenbau verwendbar ist, aber nicht unbedingt verwendet werden muss. Da geht es erstmal klassischerweise um so Geschichten wie lange, zähe, hitzebeständige, innen besonders glatte Metallrohre, aka kann man auch eine Kanone draus bauen. Und in dieses Abkommen wurde jetzt aber aufgenommen, Software, die dazu geeignet ist, in anderer Leute Rechner einzubrechen. Also genau die Exploits, von denen wir reden, die integraler Bestandteil sind von solchen Angriffen. Und Hacking Team hat ziemlich interessant gezeigt, dass dieses Wassener Abkommen schwierig ist, weil einerseits klar, kann man es moralisch verstehen, man möchte eigentlich nicht, dass wenn es schon solche Firmen gibt, die Überwachungssoftware bauen und wenn wir vielleicht mal argumentieren, dass es auch legitime Einsatzzwecke dafür gibt, dann soll es trotzdem nicht den Bösen in die Hände fallen. Das versucht dieses Wassener Abkommen zu regeln, dass man halt einfach nicht in den Sudan exportieren darf oder wohin auch immer. Leider zeigen die E-Mails von Hacking Team sehr deutlich, wie wenig das funktioniert. Also da wird halt irgendeine Stromann-Firma dazwischen geschaltet und dann wird es über zwei, drei Stufen exportiert und dann kommt die Software auch schon da an, wo sie hin soll. Da reden die auch sehr, sehr offen drüber in diesen E-Mails. Man kann die sich angucken, wo Wikileaks sind hier veröffentlicht. Der Unterschied ist einfach zu klassischer Regelung von Militärtechnologie, dass man so ein Panzer durchaus sehen kann. Der nimmt Raum ein, da ist relativ leicht zu überwachen. Da gab es auch mal Fälle, wo ein Zollbeamter in Hamburg die Landwirtschaftsmaschinen sich mal näher angucken wollte und dann hatten die plötzlich Ketten und einen Kanonenrohr. Und dann ist halt der Export geplatzt. Das ist mit Software nicht so einfach, wie jeder weiß. So eine Micro SD-Card ist nicht besonders groß. Die ist schnell mal über Grenzen geschmuggelt. Übers Internet geht das auch wunderbar, ohne Spuren zu hinterlassen. Also der Wunsch ist verständlich, diese Technologie regeln zu wollen, sodass Bösen nicht verwenden. Das Problem ist, es scheitert halt völlig in der Praxis. Gerade ist also auch dieses Wassenaer-Abkommen deswegen ein bisschen in Verruf geraten, weil auch legitime Sicherheitsforscher unter den Effekten von Wassenaer leiden. Also die plötzlich keine Sicherheitslücken nicht mehr über Grenzen diskutieren können mit der Herstellerfirma, weil es ein verbotener Export ist.
Das hört sich jetzt ein bisschen nach Vorzeitspeicherung an. Die Ungefährlichsten müssen unter Leiden, die anderen, die umgehen es eh irgendwie. Ja, das hast du aber bei vielen gesetzlichen Regelungen, dass du immer einen kollateralen Schaden hast. In dem Fall geht es ja wirklich noch darum, dass jegliche Form von Exploit erst mal als böse angesehen wird. Und wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel in, sagen wir mal, einem Produkt der Firmen, die jetzt auf deiner Seite des Teils leben, Microsoft, Google, you name it, dann kann ich nicht einfach zu denen hingehen und sagen, hier guckt mal, ich habe hier folgendes Beispiel dafür, dass euer Programm kaputt ist. Sondern in dem Fall liefere ich schon nach diesem Abkommen so gesehen eine Waffe oder ein Dual-Use-Gut. Das habe ich schon verstanden, aber das Problematische scheint zu sein, dass dieses Abkommen null dagegen hilft, dass solche Sachen irgendwie verhindert werden, aber es behindert halt, dass Leute sich drüber halten. Das heißt, diese Diskussion unter Forschern kommt dann zu mehr liegen oder gibt es dann irgendwie einen Umweg, wie man das trotzdem machen kann oder dass man dann rast und brennt?
Es gibt einen Umweg, also das ist alles noch nicht in trockenen Tüchern. Die Umsetzung nationaler Gesetze ist noch nicht fertig und deswegen ist es alles auch mit ein bisschen Vorsicht und Skepsis zu behandeln. Aber es gibt tatsächlich schon erste Forscher, die angefangen haben, Sicherheitslücken nicht mehr erstmal vertraulich an den Hersteller zu melden, sogenannte Responsible Disclosure. Also fangen wir vorne an, ich finde eine Sicherheitslücke in irgendeiner bekannten Software, sagen wir im Internet Explorer. Dann ist sozusagen der als moralisch vertretbar anerkannte Weg für alle Beteiligten, naja, man schreibt halt eine Mail an Microsoft und sagt, irgendwie passt mal auf, ihr habt da ein Problem, fix das doch mal. Und wenn man dann keine Antwort bekommt, dann schreibt man nach drei Monaten nochmal hin und sagt irgendwie, also wenn ihr jetzt nicht reagiert, dann veröffentliche ich das irgendwann. Und gibt damit dem Hersteller Zeit, die Sicherheitslücke sich anzugucken, zu fixen, einen Patch dafür zu schreiben, den Patch an seine Kunden zu schicken, sodass wenn die Information rauskommt über die Sicherheitslücke, eigentlich viele Benutzer der Software schon geschützt sind, so nennt er Responsible Disclosure. Ist aber halt nach Wassern an Export. Jetzt hat dieses Wassernabkommen eine Ausnahme, und zwar die Ausnahme existiert für quasi alles, was open source ist, alles was veröffentlicht ist und was zumindest ein Sicherheitsforscher, nämlich Stefan Esser, auch aus Deutschland getan hat, ist einfach sofort die komplette Information zu veröffentlichen. Was ein Vorgehen ist, dass man als Full Disclosure bezeichnet, hier so, hier Welt, hier ist die Sicherheitslücke, kommt damit klar. Hat den Vorteil, er hat damit nicht gegen Wassener verstoßen. Hat den eklatanten Nachteil, dass der Hersteller keine Zeit hat, darauf zu reagieren und einen Patch rauszubringen, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Leute geschützt sind. Man muss sagen, in dem konkreten Fall war das eine Sicherheitslücke, die jetzt nicht so furchtbar relevant ist. Es ging um eine Privilege Escalation auf OSX.
Eine was?
Eine Privilege Escalation.
Wenn du ein normaler Nutzer bist und Admin-Rechte bekommen möchtest, das ist eine Privilege Escalation. Das ist eine Situation. Also erstens gibt es solche Lücken in der Regel haufenweise. Und zweitens ist es auch noch nicht besonders gefährlich. Wenn ich erst mal Code ausgefüllt habe auf dem Rechner des Nutzers, gibt es immer Wege, irgendwas zu tun. Es ist jetzt nicht so, dass man dadurch aus der Ferne alle Macintoshes hacken kann oder so. Also eine vergleichsweise mittelinteressante Lücke. Und aber durchaus gemeint, die Debatte darüber anzuregen, was denn dieses Wassener Abkommen heißt und wie man mit Sicherheitslücken umgehen soll, was denn für die Gesellschaft der beste Weg ist, mit einer Sicherheitslücke umzugehen.
Und dann kommen wir an einen interessanten Punkt, dass man sich mal fragt, naja gut, aber es scheint ja doch kein so großes Problem zu sein, weil meine Güte, dann wird halt irgendwie die Sicherheitslücke veröffentlicht und dann patcht man da, gibt's ein Update und patcht man das. Ja, mein, entwegen gehen ein paar Rechnerhops, aber ganz so einfach ist es nicht, weil ja immer mehr Dinge ans Internet angeschlossen sind oder zumindest so digitalisiert werden, dass sie tatsächlich so Angriffsmöglichkeiten für so etwas bieten. Und dann kommen wir zu einer interessanten Geschichte, die auch die Tage rauszukommen ist, nämlich, dass man auch Autos mittlerweile hacken kann. Wie das genau geht, klären wir gleich vorher eine kleine Musik von Drake und The Zodiac Shadows. Shadow, Draco und the Zodiac hier im Chaosradio auf Fritz im Blumen. Und die Sendung ist mittlerweile schon an einem Punkt angekommen, wo ich sie nicht mehr einfach nur so kurz zusammenfassen kann. Aber wir können allgemein gesagt sprechen wir heute über Sicherheitslücken und den verantwortungsvollen Umgang damit bzw. wie man verhindern kann, dass die Bösen damit irgendwie so Unsinn treiben, also das möglichst verhindern kann. Und wir sind jetzt gerade ein Punkt angekommen, wo wir über sogenannte Zero Day Exploits auch reden. Also die Tatsache, wenn jemand eine Sicherheitslücke herausfindet, dann ist das Problem, wie schützt man die Leute am besten damit? Und dann gibt es verschiedene Arten und Möglichkeiten, wie man das macht. Man kann zum Beispiel erst mal dem Hersteller sagen, du Hersteller, da ist was so ein bisschen kaputt und möglicherweise sollst du das reparieren, bevor ich das an die Öffentlichkeit gebe. Aber dann gibt es andererseits wiederum das Problem, es gibt eine internationale Regelung, das Wassernahe Abkommen, das eigentlich dafür da ist, dass die Bösen nicht so eine Sicherheitslücke in die Hände kriegen. Aber dass dann, wenn jetzt ein Sicherheitsforscher in Deutschland einer Firma in den USA sagen will, du hast da ein Problem, dass das geht nicht, weil das nach dieser Regelung wiederum dann quasi schon ein Verkauf ist.
Aber war denn jetzt nicht auch schon der Hack von dem Hacking Team Verstoß gegen dieses Wassernahe Abkommen? Da sind ja auch ein paar Zero-Day-Exploits öffentlich geworden bei.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, haben die das sozusagen...
Wassernahe ist relativ neu, zumindest die Umsetzung nationaler Gesetze passiert ja gerade erst und die Lücken, die haben sie ja schon eine Weile rumzulegen.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, war es ja bei Hacking Team auch so, dass die sich durchaus so am klaren waren, dass die mit Diktaturen und Regimes, die eher so schmutzig sind, handeln und das dann über Zwischenfirmen gemacht haben. Eine andere interessante Sache war, dass sie wohl interessanterweise auch staatsnahe Fürsprecher hatten, die auch irgendwie so meinten, ja komm lass mal irgendwie 5° sein. Das ist Berichterstattung, die ich jetzt auch nur so gelesen und zur Kenntnis genommen habe, aber wenn die wirklich stimmt, dann wäre das natürlich auch noch mal eine ziemlich heiße Geschichte.
Also es kann sein, dass sie dagegen andere Embargobestimmungen verstoßen haben. Das ist nicht was in dem konkreten Fall, wo sie tatsächlich umgearbeitet haben.
Also jetzt sind ja die Zero Days nicht mehr Zero Days.
Ach so, du meinst, du meinst zu sagen, dass die Leute, die beim Hacking Team eingestiegen sind und diese Daten veröffentlicht haben? Also das ist übrigens noch ein anderer Satz an der Punkt, die, also weil wir gerade auch so ein bisschen über die Ethik des Hackens sprechen, ist denn der Einbruch beim Hacking Team eigentlich der Hackerethik zufolge ethisch richtiges Handeln eigentlich nicht, oder?
Puh, ist jetzt wie bei Star Wars, am Ende ist immer, wer du grad bist, kommt drauf an, wer die Guten sind. Und wenn man dann bei den Rebellen verhindert, dass der Todesstern da mit den armen Klonensoldaten da in die Luft gesprengt wird, dann ist es ja auch vielleicht ein erstrebenswertes Ziel.
Also ich halte es schon für gerechtfertigt. Also der Fall hat erstens dokumentiert, wie weit verbreitet tatsächlich die Zusammenarbeit mit Regimes ist, dass das Software zugeliefert wird, hat dokumentiert, wie der ganze O-Day-Markt funktioniert. Also muss man ja auch sagen, es gibt ja nicht nur die Varianten, ich veröffentliche die Sicherheitslücke oder ich sage dem Hersteller Bescheid, es gibt noch die Variante, von der reden wir hier. Ich verkaufe die auf dem grauen bis schwarzen Markt an jemanden, der damit irgendwo einbrechen möchte und sage dem Hersteller nicht Bescheid, sage der Öffentlichkeit nicht Bescheid.
Aber die interessante Sache ist halt sagen, man heißt sozusagen den Einbruch gut, also die Anwendung von Mitteln, die man normalerweise nicht gut heißt. Also das ist halt so ein bisschen, also klar, irgendwie man stellt sich hin und sagt so haha Hacking Team, die haben es verdient, aber man will eigentlich nicht, dass diese Mittel allgemein... Ich glaube, es geht gar nicht mal so um dieses ja ha, die haben es verdient, sondern es ist halt eine der wenigen Möglichkeiten, also korrigiere mich, falls ich irgendwas übersehe, überhaupt erst mal aufzuzeigen, was da eigentlich im Hintergrund alles abläuft.
Darf ich da kurz reingerätschen? Wir haben heute genau den Fall wieder.
Ich meine Landesverrat.
Hallo?
Ja, das ist es. Ich wäre jetzt auch fast drauf gekommen. Ja, letztendlich ist es eine ähnliche Geschichte. Aber es ist auch ein bisschen Selbstjustiz.
Die Blogger heute, die da oder die Blogger von Netzpolitik, also die Journalisten dort, haben auch dann im Rahmen des ihnen zugestandenen Impetos dann eben ihre Möglichkeiten benutzt und diese Dokumente veröffentlichen, weil sie gedacht haben, dass ein überwiegender Teil der Gesellschaft daran Interesse hat. Deswegen denke ich auch, dass es ein überwiegender Teil der Gesellschaft Interesse daran hat, zu gucken, was da wieder das Hacking Team sich geriert hat.
Aber da muss man schon eine Entscheidung machen, weil was Netzpolitik macht, ist ja über Dinge berichten, die ihnen von anderen Leuten zugetragen wurden. Also quasi wenn die über den Hacking Team Hack schreiben, das ist ja quasi deren Position. Na ja, da wollte ich gerade drauf kommen sozusagen. Und die haben diese Informationen ja von Leuten, die in dem Inneren der Ministerien gearbeitet haben und ihnen diese Informationen zugetragen haben. Da geht es also um Whistle Blower. Und die Leute, die beim Hacking Team eingebrochen sind, das ist tatsächlich, also was du jetzt sagen, schön euphemistisch, irgendwie Voss-Full Whistle Blowing, die sind ja von außen da eingebrochen. Und das ist ja der wichtige Unterschied. Es ist schon schwierig, oder?
Ich glaube, das muss dann am Ende nachträglich entschieden werden. Die Gesellschaft muss dort jetzt drauf gucken und für sich entscheiden, ob das okay war oder nicht. Und beim nächsten Mal wird es dann moralische Standards geben, die sich da jetzt an diesem Fall vielleicht entzündet haben. Also sprich, dass die dann mal ausformuliert werden, dass man darüber spricht. Und das kann natürlich immer nur an solchen Fällen passieren, wo man dann mal sieht, wie die genauen Folgen sind, wo man dann am plastischen Beispiel sieht, ob dort die Zivilgesellschaft am Ende einen Nettogewinn oder einen Nettoverlust rausgezogen hat.
Aber es ist komplizierter. Aber dann kommen wir jetzt doch noch zu dem Thema, was die Sicherheitslücken mittlerweile so anrichten können. Und sie können tatsächlich viel mehr machen, als nur da werden Rechner übernommen, da wird Kommunikation abgehört. Was natürlich an und für sich schon schlimm genug sein kann. Insbesondere wenn es darum geht, dass man vielleicht ein Oppositioneller in einem Regime ist und das Leib und Leben davon abhängen, dass Kommunikation nicht aufliegt. Aber es gibt auch andere Dinge, die die richtige Welt beeinflussen können. Und das ist zum Beispiel, dass Dinge gehackt werden und damit Unsinn getrieben wird, die Gebrauchsgegenstände sind mehr oder weniger, aber mittlerweile Internetanschluss haben. Oder zumindest ein oder mehrere Computer an Bord. Und eine so eine Sache ist, und das ist ganz spannend und passt halt schönerweise heute auch hier rein, sind Autos. Da gab es nämlich in der letzten Woche, das ist bekannt geworden, dass tatsächlich ein Auto gehackt worden ist und man damit machen kann, was man will von außen. Wer es das genau ist, wird uns jetzt vielleicht Andreas, wenn ich es richtig in Ordnung habe, erzählen, was da passiert ist.
Genau. Also es ist eigentlich eine Geschichte, die für jeden, der sich mit Computersicherheit auskennt, völlig offensichtlich ist. So ein modernes Auto hat jede Menge Computer an Bord. Und Computer, wir beherrschen halt die Technologie noch nicht wirklich, Computer ohne Sicherheitslücken zu bauen. Ergo kann man Autos auch hacken. Das war natürlich erstmal graue Theorie, bis einige Leute angefangen haben, sich tatsächlich damit zu beschäftigen. Es gibt ein paar im Untergrund, die machen das schon länger. Die erzählen in der Regel dann darauf ab, den Tachostand zurückzudrehen und ähnliche Geschichten. Darum geht es nicht, sondern es geht darum, was kann man denn sonst noch so mit so modernen Autos machen, wenn man irgendwie die Kontrolle drüber hat. Und Charlie Miller und Chris Wallaseck haben also schon vor zwei Jahren angefangen, sich das mal näher anzugucken. Und es gab dann die ersten Veröffentlichungen, wo sie jedes Auto hat so einen Wartungsstecker. Habt ihr vielleicht schon mal gesehen. OBD2 Stecker heißt, der ist in der Nähe des Lenkrades. Da haben sie einen Stecker reingesteckt und dann mal angefangen mit den Paketen rumzuspielen, die sie so auf den Bussen gesehen haben. Die haben jetzt einen Stecker dran.
Pakete, Busse, was?
Ja, ja, so ein modernes Auto ist also nicht nur, da ist nicht nur ein Computer drin, da sind ganz, ganz viele Computer drin. Die heißen da nicht Computer, die heißen ECUs. Was mal für Engine Control Unit stand, mittlerweile Electronic Control Unit heißt, weil nicht nur die Engine damit gesteuert wird, sondern alles. Also wenn man sein Auto aufschraubt, so Kästen, wo Drähte rauskommen. Und davon hat es ein modernes Auto bis zu 70 mit auch teilweise sehr beeindruckender Rechenleistung, weil die eine ganze Menge machen. Das ist, also geht los mit dem Mäusekino, das heißt irgendwie das Armaturenbrett, das man hat, da ist ein Computer dran, der das steuert. Geht weiter mit dem Entertainment System, also das Radio, das Navigationssystem, das ist auch ein Computer. Die eigentliche Motorsteuerung, weil elektronische Einspritzung, was man da heutzutage alles hat. Und das ABS-System, das Airbag-System, das kleine Ding, das hinten den Scheibenwischer an- und ausmacht, die Abstandsensoren, die Servolenkung, also die Liste ist mittlerweile echt lang. Und je teuer das Auto, desto mehr hat man davon. Und die sind miteinander verbunden, die müssen natürlich auch miteinander reden, über sogenannte Busse. Also im Prinzip Datenkabel, auf denen sie Informationen austauschen. Der klassische Bus im Fahrzeugbereich, der sogenannte CAN-Bus, C-A-N. Bei modernen Autos gibt es da noch ein paar mehr Typen, unter anderem Flexray und LIN. Und das Ding ist, dass beim Design dieser Autos eigentlich das Maßgebliche war, die Sicherheit im Sinne von Safety. Das heißt, es soll nicht plötzlich gegen eine Wand fahren oder plötzlich das Gaspedal runterdrücken, obwohl man es gar nicht gedrückt hat, wie bei Toyota. Und die Dinger vertrauen einander. Das heißt, auf dem Bus, wenn einer sagt, ich bin das Gaspedal und der Fahrzeugführer möchte gerne, dass das Auto schneller fährt, dann sagt die Motorsteuerung, okay, habe ich wahrgenommen. Ich sag mal der Einspritzpumpe Bescheid, dass sie ein bisschen mehr Benzin geben soll und Luftzufuhr dreh ich auch auf. Also so ungefähr funktionieren moderne Autos. Siehst du mal wie früher, dass man aufs Gaspedal tritt und dann ist da so ein Draht, der eine Klappe am Vergaser zieht. So ein Auto habt ihr bestimmt auch alle mal gefahren, wenn ihr alt genug seid. Sondern ist alles drahtlos. Selbst die Lenkung ist mittlerweile bei vielen Autos indirekt. Man dreht am Lenkrad und ob jetzt nach halb der Lenkraddrehung das Rad doll bewegt oder bloß ein bisschen bewegt, hängt von der Geschwindigkeit ab, mit der man fährt. Aus Sicherheitsgründen, dass man auf der Autobahn nicht so leicht die Spur verliert und so weiter und so fort. Die Bremsen funktionieren so, also früher war es auch mal ein Hydrauliksystem, man hat aufs Pedal getreten und dann hat man einen kleinen Kolben reingedrückt, wo dann per Öldruck die Bremsbacken auf die Bremse gedrückt wurden. Das ist heute auch nicht mehr so, man hat da ein Pedal, da tritt man drauf und dann geht ein Signal an die Bremse. Ich glaube aus Backup-Gründen haben sie immer noch eine Hydraulik, aber die wird eigentlich von der Bremsunterstützung, also naja größtenteils macht es der Computer. Und all das funktioniert über diese kleinen Kommandos und all das setzt voraus, wir sind hier alle gutmütige Teilnehmer im Elektroniksystem. Was die gemacht haben, ist sich auf diese Busse drauf zu hängen und zu sagen, ich bin übrigens auch das Gaspedal und der hat jetzt ganz doll Gas gegeben. Oder ich bin der Schalter vorne im Armaturenbrett, mach doch mal bitte die Fenster runter. Da gibt es also von vor zwei Jahren die ersten Videos, wo sie Journalist fährt Auto und die beiden Hacker sitzen mit ihren Laptops hacken, grinsen auf der Rückbank und tipp tipp tipp tipp enter und plötzlich bremst das Auto und so nummern. Also schon gezeigt, was eigentlich völlig klar ist, wenn man sich die Architektur des Autos anguckt, aber wie das immer so ist, damit die Leute es verstehen, muss man es auch mal zeigen.
Okay, warte. Und bei dieser Sache vor zwei Jahren mussten sie in dem Auto sitzen und mussten mit dem, den Rechner per Kabel mit dem Auto verbinden.
Genau.
Und was dann passiert ist, erzählen wir nach den Nachrichten über Wetter und Verkehr.
Das ist ja fast wie über Buzzfeed hier.
So sieht's aus.
Also wenn Berlin was kann, dann ja wohl die drei großen F. Feste, Feiern und Flughäfen.
Also lasst uns Feste feiern.
Ein legendäres Festival auf einem legendären Flughafen. Und das zum ersten Mal in Europa.
Britz präsentiert das Lollapalooza Festival.
Mit den Beatstakes Sam Smith, Bastille und Siv. Mit Martin Garrix, Deichkind und Macklemore featuring Ryan Lewis. Und das sind längst noch nicht alle.
Samstag 12.
und Sonntag 13. September. Auf dem Flughafen Tempelhof.
So lange es noch Karten gibt, gibt es Karten überall wo es Karten gibt. Fritz Nachrichten.
Mit Timo Maschewski.
Die Bundesanwaltschaft hat Ermittlungen gegen zwei Journalisten wegen Landesverrats eingeleitet. Die beiden arbeiten für den Blog netzpolitik.org. Dort haben sie Informationen und Dokumente des Verfassungsschutzes online gestellt, die teilweise als geheim eingestuft waren. In den Dokumenten gibt es um eine Ausweitung der Überwachung von sozialen Netzwerken. Der Gründer von netzpolitik.org, Beckettal, sagte Fritz, man habe zeigen wollen, wie skuppellos die Bundesregierung versuche, die Überwachung trotz der Snowden-Enthüllungen weiter auszubauen. Die Bereitschaft der Deutschen, neue Flüchtlinge aufzunehmen, ist gesunken. Im neuen ARD Deutschland-Trend haben zwar 57% der Befragten gesagt, sie seien für eine Beibehaltung oder Steigerung der Aufnahme zahlen. Auf der anderen Seite ist aber der Anteil der Menschen gestiegen, die wollen, dass künftig weniger Menschen aufgenommen werden. 38% haben das gesagt, das sind 17% mehr als noch Anfang des Jahres. Beim Computersystem des Berliner Senats gibt es anscheinend eine Sicherheitslücke. Nach Informationen der RWB-Abendschau laufen rund 200-320 Server so rum, der Verwaltung noch mit dem veralteten Windows 2003. Dafür stellt der Hersteller Microsoft seit zwei Wochen keine Sicherheitsupdates mehr zur Verfügung. Experten befürchten deshalb, dass Hacker über Schwachstellen in dieses Thema eindringen und Daten abgreifen könnten. In Nigeria hat das Militär rund 60 Geiseln aus der Hand der Islamistengruppe Boko Haram befreit. Unter den Geretteten sind überwiegend Frauen und Kinder. Sie waren von den Islamisten in zwei Lagern im Nordwesten Nigérias festgehalten worden. Boko Haram versucht seit Jahren mit Gewaltanschlägen und Entführungen einen islamischen Staat in Nigeria aufzubauen.
Das Wetter.
Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Steglitz sind es 13 Grad und in Pankow 14 Grad, Rangsdorf meldet 12 Grad, Frankfurt oder 13 Grad, in Falkensee sind es 14 Grad und in Manchano noch 15 Grad. Die Nacht über klart der Himmel stellenweise auf, vor allem im Norden sehen aber auch einige Wolkenfälle dadurch. Trotzdem bleibt es meistens trocken und es kann sich noch bis auf 8 Grad abkühlen. Morgen viel Sonne, vor allem im Süden. Dazu Höchstwerte bis 22 Grad. Und auch das Wochenende geht's freundlich weiter. Es wird auch wieder etwas wärmer. Stadtverkehr Berlin auf der A111 der Stadtautobahn. Statt auswärts ist der Tunnel Ortskern Tegel komplett gesperrt. Da wird die Fahrbahn neu gemacht. In Tegel gibt's außerdem Probleme auf der Gorki-Straße, im Bereich Buddestraße, da gehen die S-Bahnschranken nicht mehr hoch. Auch mehrere BVG-Buslinien müssen umgeleitet werden. Das soll wohl auch noch die ganze Nacht so bleiben. In Brandenburg gibt's Probleme auf der A2-Berlin Richtung Magdeburg. Zwischen Lenin und Netzen wird gebaut. Da ist nur eine Spur frei und das kann etwas länger dauern. Und auch auf der A10, dem östlichen Berliner Ring, Richtung Dreieck-Sprayau gibt's Probleme. Da ist zwischen Rüdersdorf und Erkner die linke Spur nur noch frei. Wo es geht, euch eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Oder diesen Sound. Dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit Maurice Geider. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de.
Herzlich willkommen zur letzten halben Stunde Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz. Dabei sind Danimo vom Chaos Computer Club, hallo und guten Abend. Andreas Bruck. Und Erdgeist.
Schönen guten Abend.
Erdgeist wollte gerade noch was zu den Nachrichten sagen.
Nein, ich hatte mich nur an den Blog ein wenig gestört. Das heißt das Blog.
Völlig richtig.
So aber eigentlich geht es heute um Sicherheitslücken und wie man damit umgehen kann. Wir haben schon in den vergangenen 90 Minuten darüber geredet. Wie das funktioniert, wie die Verantwortung voller Umgang damit aussieht, wie man verhindern kann, dass der eigene Code von den Bösen verwendet wird. Und wir reden jetzt gerade darüber, was für Auswirkungen es eigentlich haben kann, wenn es solche Sicherheitslücken gibt und dass es da auch mittlerweile mehr geht als Computer. Wir sind gerade beim Auto angekommen und Andreas hatte gerade schon erklärt, was beim Auto eigentlich alles mittlerweile von einem Computer gesteuert wird. Und die Kurzzusammenfassung ist alles. Und jetzt hat auch schon erzählt, vor zwei Jahren haben Hacker zum ersten Mal gezeigt, dass sie das auch alles irgendwie selbst von ferne steuern können. Und von ferne war damals aber noch, man muss in dem Auto drin sitzen und dann ein Kabel in das Auto reinlegen und dann kann man das System irgendwie hacken. Aber was ist dann passiert, Andreas?
Es ist etwas passiert, was euch alle völlig überraschen wird. Also wie wir alle wissen, so Computer können gehackt werden und Computer, die man ans Internet hängt, können übers Internet gehackt werden. Um es mal ein bisschen vereinfacht darzustellen, aber nicht völlig falsch. Und jetzt sind die Automobilhersteller also auf die glorios Idee gekommen, dass so ein Auto am Internet eigentlich auch eine ganz tolle Sache wäre. Aus verschiedenen Gründen, unter anderem damit übers Internet jederzeit keine Ahnung, aktuelle Verkehrsmeldungen abgerufen werden können, aber auch damit man seinen Twitter-Feed angucken kann.
Oder damit du mit dem Handy dein Auto entsperren kannst.
Genau, dass man aus der Ferne schon mal über die App in seinem Mobiltelefon die Standheizung anmachen will, damit man einen warmen Hintern hat, wenn man des Winters in sein Auto einsteigt. Also der Anwendungsfälle gibt es da viele. Und jetzt haben tatsächlich auch wieder Miller und Wallasec gezeigt, erstmal einem Wire-Journalisten, weil man muss ja ein bisschen trommeln. Und nächste Woche gibt es in Las Vegas die Präsentation dazu, dass das durchaus auch aus der Ferne mit solchen Autos funktioniert, da alles zu tun, was man tun möchte, wenn sie im Internet dranhängen. Konkret handelt es sich um ein Modell des Herstellers Chrysler mit der Marke Jeep, also ein Jeep Cherokee, der da angegriffen wurde, der verfügt über einen Feature namens Uconnect, was halt genau diese Internet-Schnittstelle ist. Und was sie also gezeigt haben unter ein bisschen zweifelhaften, sehr spektakulären Bedingungen, nämlich auf einem befahrenen Highway mit einem Journalisten drin, der dieses Auto durch die Gegend fuhr, ist, wie sie übers Internet in das Auto eingegriffen haben. Also erstmal die Musik laut gedreht, dann die Fenster runter gemacht und dann plötzlich Gas weggenommen, sodass das Auto also auf dem Highway immer langsamer wurde und irgendwann stehen blieb. Und was natürlich auch beliebige andere Möglichkeiten für die Erzeugung von Unfällen mit solchen Autos beinhaltet. Also eigentlich ein sehr, sehr heikles Thema und eine große Gefahr, die übersteht.
So, und jetzt haben wir einen Punkt, wo wir wieder bei der Sicherheitszirkue zurückkommen. Die haben das ja entdeckt und die haben auch schon, also man muss auch sagen, die haben das an dem Jeep Cherokee gezeigt, weil der sozusagen die beste Angriffsmöglichkeit geboten hat. Die haben aber eine Liste von Autos und es gibt noch ein anderes Modell, was genauso leicht angegriffen werden kann und dann so, wo es halt immer schwieriger wird. Aber das ist halt kein bedauerlicher Einzelfall, sondern das ist das, was jetzt auf uns zukommt. Und die haben aber mit der Firma auch schon geredet.
Genau, die sind vorher dahin gelaufen, haben also das getan, was man Responsible Disclosure nennt. Vorher hat der Firma Bescheid gesagt, so wir werden das jetzt veröffentlichen. Und dann gab es wahrscheinlich Heulen und Wehklagen. Und die Firma Chrysler hat jetzt sich entschlossen, USB-Sticks mit Updates an alle ihre Kunden zu verschicken. Also man muss sich das so vorstellen, man kriegt einen Brief, da ist ein USB-Stick drin. Den steckt man dann an seinem Auto in den USB-Slot, wo man sonst sein iPhone anhängt oder sein Memorystick für die MP3s reinsteckt. Und dann sagt das Ding, bitte updaten, dann kommt so ein Ladebalken und dann ist irgendwann geupdatet und die Sicherheitslücke ist beseitigt. Betrug 1, 4 Millionen Modelle.
Als Hacker würde ich mir jetzt Adressen von Jeep Cherokee Besitzern suchen und ihnen Briefen mit USB-Sticks schicken.
Das ist die nächste Frage, wie gut ist die Signaturprüfung bei den Updates? Ja, aber auch wieder ein Vektor, ne? Also es gibt verschiedene Angriffsvektoren, über die man an so ein Auto rankommen kann und drahtlos über Internet ist natürlich der bequemste. Aber zu USB-Sticks, da sind ja jede Menge Daten drauf, die dann vom Navi oder was auch immer gelesen werden. Also einen Fall ist mir bekannt, da kann man per USB-Stick, sondern unter Points of Interest ins Navigationssystem einspielen. Also man klickt halt auf der Karte irgendwie, ja, da wohnt ich, da wohnt die Oma und dann kann man da ein XML-Datei draus machen und die da reinstecken. Und wenn man die XML-Datei geschickt gestaltet, dann stürzt das System halt ab. Und das ist also durchaus vorstellbar, dass man eine Sicherheitslücke findet, die sich darüber ausnutzen lässt, dass jemand etwas in das USB reinsteckt.
Und jetzt ist der Punkt, die sind halt zu dieser Firma gegangen und haben gesagt, hier ist Sicherheitslücke, dann veröffentlicht sie das jetzt, es gibt diese USB-Sticks. Aber wenn man so mal nachguckt, wie realistischerweise, wie viele Leute Updates machen, dann ist halt auf jeden Fall klar, es wird in näherer Zukunft zwei Sachen eingetreten sein, weil es wird Autos geben, die nicht geupdatet wurden und es wird relativ breites Wissen darüber vorhanden sein, wie die Sicherheitslücken funktionieren.
Davon ist auszugehen, zumal wir in einer Situation leben, wo wenn man mit seinem Auto zum TÜV fährt, sich niemand die Versionsstände der Software anguckt. Also es findet ja nicht mal eine Prüfung statt, ob man denn auch mit allen Patches durch die Gegend fährt oder vielleicht mal wieder updaten muss. Also ganzen Probleme, die wir von Rechnern so kennen, die wir mit dem nächsten Auto auch haben.
So, jetzt ist aber der Punkt und dann sind wir wieder bei dem eigentlichen Thema, die Sendung, nämlich dem Umgang mit Sicherheitsschwankungen. Was macht man denn als Hacker? Also man ist jetzt Hacker und hat halt so sein System komplett auseinandergenommen und hat jetzt so eine Wahl, wie man es macht. Und jetzt ist so die, jetzt finde ich ja, ist was die jetzt gemacht haben, nämlich als erster Firma gehen und der Zeit lassen. Und dann kann man halt sagen, okay, die habt's ja gewusst und so. Aber die nehmen ja, man könnte sagen, die nehmen ja trotzdem in Kauf, dass jetzt diese Leute mit den ungepatchten Autos rumfahren und die Sicherheitslücke bekannt ist. Also warum wird das überhaupt an die Öffentlichkeit bringen?
Ja, vermutlich. Also erstens, dass ich die Sicherheitslücke entdecke, heißt ja noch lange nicht, dass nicht jemand an, dass sie nicht auch schon entdeckt hat. Und zum zweiten auch, um überhaupt auf das Problem aufmerksam zu machen. Also gerade in dem Fall, man kann jetzt über die Mittel diskutieren. Ja, auf einer tatsächlich befahrenen Straße das auszuprobieren ist grenzwertig. Aber auf jeden Fall hat das in der Industrie eine Debatte losgetreten. Das ist irgendwie ein Problem, das lange Zeit stiefmütterlich betrachtet wurde. Also gerade bei den ersten Veröffentlichungen vor ein oder zwei Jahren, da gibt es einen VW-Presse-Sprecher, der sich hinstellt und sagt, irgendwie ist alles viel zu kompliziert. Das wird nie in der Praxis einer machen oder ähnliche Geschichten. Oder es heißt, unsere Autos sind unhackbar, hört man halt ständig. Und das überhaupt angefangen wird, darauf Wert zu legen und auch die Ressourcen dafür zu alluzieren, dass die Autos entsprechend gehärtet werden, dass Sicherheitslücken gesucht und gepatcht werden, dass Update-Mechanismen eingerichtet werden, dass vielleicht demnächst der TÜV mal anfängt, Versionsstände zu kontrollieren. Das erfordert einen gewissen öffentlichen Druck. Und in dem Fall ist es eine Abwägung, die ganz, ganz klar ist. Es ist ein Patch draußen. Die Information, wie man die Lücke ausnutzt, ist noch nicht komplett draußen. Da müssen wir mal gucken, wie viel da überhaupt rausgeht. Aber es wurde gezeigt, dass es geht. Und da kann man natürlich spekulieren, wenn man weiß, dass es geht. Wen gibt es denn noch, der sowas kann und vielleicht damit Schindluder treibt? Genauso gut könnte ja ein Hacker hingehen und sagen, naja, ich richte eine Webseite ein im Darknet. Und da kann man dann 1000 Bitcoin bezahlen und mir eine Vehicle ID geben. Und dann fährt dieses Auto gegen den Baum. Ist ja auch ein vorstellbares Geschäftsmodell. Und das will man ja verhindern, dass sowas nicht passiert als Gesellschaft. Und dafür muss man nicht Strukturen schaffen. Dazu muss man auch mal über Sicherheitslücken reden.
Na ja, jetzt sagst du als Gesellschaft Strukturen schaffen. Aber das, was man erlebt und was jetzt auch so zu sagen, was du denkst, ist ja der, das ist ein relativ kleiner Kreis von Leuten, die das verhandeln. Nämlich sozusagen auf der einen Seite die Hacker, auf der anderen Seite die wenigen Entscheider in der Industrie, die dann sagen können, okay wir forschen daran, wir verlassen das halt lieber. Das ist ja keine gesellschaftliche Debatte.
Na doch, da ist ja ein gewisser Druck dazwischen. Also interessiert das die Leute oder interessiert das die Leute nicht, dass man halt aus der Ferne das Auto gegen den Baum fahren lassen kann?
Schau dir die Diskussion an, die es gab im Zusammenhang mit einer Untersuchung, die der ADAC dann in Auftrag gegeben hat. Da ging es um das Remote, aufschließen von einem gewissen Fahrzeugtyp. Das war dann auch eine Aktion, die der ADAC wirklich quasi begleitet hat und überhaupt erst ermöglicht hat, dass man das ausprobiert. Und ich würde jetzt mal diskutieren im Kontext Autos, ist der ADAC schon als Teil der Gesellschaft oder als Teil der relevanten Gesellschaft in dem Fall zu betrachten? Also das ist größer als jetzt nur ein paar Nerds und ein paar Manager, finde ich schon. Nur in dem einen Fall, aber ist das immer so? Es ist letztendlich, wie du schon sagtest, eine Fallgeschichte, aber je mehr es passiert, desto krasser die Beispiele. Also sowas lebt natürlich immer auch von medialer Aufmerksamkeit. Mediale Aufmerksamkeit kriegst du je krasser dein Hack ist. Aber die mediale Aufmerksamkeit ist ja völlig unabhängig davon, ob du die tatsächliche Anleitung veröffentlicht, die mediale Aufmerksamkeit in dem Fall ist ja dadurch gegeben, dass du dieses krassere Beispiel machst, dass du sagst, hier der Typ sitzt in einem Auto und beschreibt halt, wie krass das für ein Gefühl ist, wenn du mitten auf der Autobahn bist, dann wird das Auto auf einmal langsamer. Das ist ja völlig egal, ob jetzt in der Öffentlichkeit ist, wie das genau funktioniert oder nicht.
Da ist ja die Geschichte. Tatsächlich ist ja die Information, wie das genau funktioniert, noch gar nicht raus.
Aber das ist doch angekündigt, dass sie das machen wollen.
Ich weiß nicht, in welches Detail das geht.
Sie haben eine Deadline gesetzt, aber haben nicht gesagt, inwiefern sie das veröffentlichen werden. Sie werden das auf einer Sicherheitskonferenz veröffentlichen. Aber sie haben noch nicht einen gesagt, zumindest nicht öffentlich, bis zu welchen Details sie das tun werden.
Ich lese über uns gerade einen Tweet von einem der Hacker. Offensichtlich hat Chrysler einen Weg gefunden, wie sie für ungepätschte Fahrzeuge den Internetzugang unterbinden können. Möglicherweise ist da der Stöpsel gefunden, den man reinstecken kann, dass da nichts Schlimmes passiert. Auch bei ungepätschten Fahrzeugen, dass die Leute gezwungen werden, einen Patch einzuspielen.
Ach so, also man sagt, kein automatischer Patch, aber man sagt einem ungepätschten Auto, du bist nicht mehr im Internet drin, bevor du gepätscht bist.
Genau.
Das ist ja immerhin eine Lösung.
Das wäre ja auch immer ganz praktisch für so Rechner zu Hause bei den Leuten, die ihre solvenliche Abdehnung halten.
Das machen ISPs ja teilweise, alleine um sich selber zu schützen. Die machen einfach gewisse Ports oder sogar ganze Verbindungen, also ganze koppelnde Haushalte ab. Wie, wenn die kontrollieren auf dem Rechner, welches Software da läuft? Nein, nein. Wenn die einen Angriff feststellen, der aufgrund einer Sicherheitslücke erst möglich ist, dann gibt es ISPs, soweit ich weiß nicht, unbedingt in Deutschland, die würden dann einfach präventiv Ports schließen, soweit das möglich ist, aber in anderen Ländern ist das durchaus üblich. Dann einfach zuzumachen, gerade um sich selber zu schützen.
Was es für Firmen tatsächlich gibt, ist so ein Agent, der auf dem Rechner läuft und der guckt, ob alles gepatcht ist. Erst wenn alles gepatcht ist, sagt er dem Netzwerk alles gut. Wenn nicht alles gut ist, dann nimmt man ein Quarantänennetzwerk und kann nichts machen, außer Patches einzuspielen. Man darf erst alles eigentliche Firmenetzwerk, doch, doch wirklich.
Das und ein VN-Scan, ja.
Dann darf man erst an die eigentlichen Firmen daten dran, wenn man alles gepatcht hat.
Das klingt gut für den Rest der Familie, die sich nicht selber um den Rechner kümmern wollen. Aber ich finde noch eine andere Frage nicht unspannend, und zwar, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, ist die Untersuchung, die diese beiden Leute gemacht haben, ein Forschungsprojekt von der DARPA. Das ist wiederum in den USA. Die Leute sind die so, auch vor allem an Militärforschung, irgendwie viel Eigennutzen haben.
Das ist der Forschungsarm des US-Militärs, kann man sagen.
Genau.
Das heißt, alle Autos sind per Computer gesteuert, der Forschungsarm des Militärs bezahlt, dass diese Sicherheitslücken rauskommen. Das hatte so ein bisschen Geschmack, insbesondere, wo am Anfang der Sendung gesagt wurde, eigentlich wollen wir gar nicht, dass Militärs mit unseren Sicherheitslücken was zu tun haben, geschweige denn die ausnutzen können. Und dann die spannende Frage, die ich finde, die dahintersteckt, ist, wenn wir wollen, dass Sicherheitslücken verantwortungsvoll damit umgegangen wird, dann müssen wir dafür sorgen, dass Sicherheitslücken von Leuten gefunden werden, die überhaupt damit verantwortungsvoll umgehen wollen. Die müssen aber auch von irgendwas leben. Brauchen wir also so eine Art staatliches Sicherheitslückenforschungsteam?
Ja, da muss man dann immer wieder Angst haben, dass sie das nicht veröffentlichen. Also das mit DARPA ist eine spannende Geschichte. Das wird da auch ein bisschen anders gesehen als hier. Also hier ist es schon androhig, wenn man vom Militär Geld nimmt. Da ist es völlig normal. Da lässt jeder sein Forschungsprojekt von der DARPA finanzieren.
Aber bei uns haben wir doch das BSI, das genau dafür da ist.
Ja, tun die das? Nee, die machen keine Forschungsförderung. Doch, doch, doch.
Weiß nicht wie zufällig, ja genau.
DARPA hat zum Beispiel auch die Forschung fürs Internet finanziert. Also meine Meinung ist, wenn das Forschungsergebnis hinterher allen zur Verfügung steht, der Öffentlichkeit zur Verfügung steht und nicht irgendwo in einem Tresor verschwindet, dann darf das, finde ich, auch das Militär bezahlen. Das finde ich völlig in Ordnung.
Es gibt da dieses Internet, das nicht zuletzt von der DARPA überhaupt erst gebaut wurde.
Es hat sich bei Sicherheitslücken im Computerbereich dieses Bug Bounty Ding etabliert. Also die Firmen sagen, wenn du als Außenstehender uns eine Sicherheitslücke reportest, dann gibt es da Geld dafür. Und das ist tatsächlich was, wovon manche Leute lieben. Wenn man bei Pwn2O mitmacht, dann kann man auch mal 100.000, 150.000 Euro abräumen. Normalerweise, wenn man eine Sicherheitslücke an Pwn2O reportet...
Aber da kannst du schon wieder zu Problemen kommen, dass das Wasser nahe abkommt, wenn man das auch schon sprachend da reinfunkt, oder?
In der Tat. Die Probleme werden den Leuten gerade bewusst. Das ist alles nochmal auf den Prüfstand gestellt und zurückgestellt. Da werden wir sicherlich noch ein bisschen Bewegung drin sehen, was da passiert und wie das funktionieren wird. Aber im Prinzip ist diese Bug Bounty Geschichte ein sehr richtiger Ansatz. Man sieht halt ein, so Sicherheitsforschung kostet Zeit. Und Kenntnis über eine Sicherheitslücke ist Geld wert. Und das ist meistens auch für den Hersteller billiger, tatsächlich diese Sicherheitslücke zu kaufen, als den Imageschaden in Kauf zu nehmen, wenn mal wieder alles gehackt wird darüber. Also die 10.000, 15.000 Dollar, das interessiert die ja in dem Sinne nicht. Das ist für die kein Geld im großen Maßstab. Aber dann mal wieder 5% Markteinteile an den Konkurrenten zu verlieren, das ist richtig Geld.
Okay, könnt ihr vielleicht noch zum Abschluss sagen, einen generellen Leitfaden für den, wie Hacker verantwortungsvoll mit Sicherheitslücken und dem Finden derselben umgehen sollten, geben? Wollt ihr das jeder Einzelnen machen oder gibt es eine einheitliche Meinung?
Das ist glaube ich...
Also ich würde so ein Auto, das ich erstmal aufgemacht habe, oder wenn ich das großflächig habe, dann würde ich mir auf dem Weg zur Arbeit erstmal eine Gasse freibachen. So ganz dezent nach links und rechts lenken lassen, dann kann man damit durchfahren. Das ist doch praktisch.
Oder so ein Physical Botnet, also man stellt sich bloß vor, man drückt auf den Knopf und es fahren 1000 S-Klasse vor.
Ich dachte jetzt eigentlich, ihr sagt zum Schluss noch etwas verantwortungsvolles für den angehenden Jungen Hacker, der vielleicht...
Vielleicht doch. Die All-Days meist bieten zu verkaufen im Untergrund, halte ich persönlich für moralisch nicht vertretbar. Ob der Kaufer jetzt, ob das Kriminelle sind, die einem versuchen, einen Trojaner unter zu jubeln, um das Bankkonto leer zu räumen. Ob das irgendwelche Firmen sind, die für zweifelhafte Geheimdienste noch zweifelhafter Länder über Wachenssoftware programmieren. Ob das die nächste, in Anführungszeichen, Cyberbombe ist, die dann dafür sorgt, dass in einem Land der Strom komplett ausfällt. Das ist für mich alles kein verantwortungsvoller Umgang. Ich finde, man hat meiner Meinung nach die freie Wahl zwischen Full Disclosure und Responsible Disclosure. Und musste einfach ein bisschen abwägen, was im Einzelfall der bessere Weg ist. Microsoft wurde tatsächlich mit Full Disclosure dazu gezwungen, sich mein Sicherheitsprogramm zuzulegen. Also überhaupt sich darum zu kümmern. Zu XP-Zeiten war das richtig schlimm. Dann haben Leute angefangen, einmal die Woche eine Sicherheitslücke zu veröffentlichen. Bis Bill Gates persönlich gesagt hat, mir reicht's. Die ganze Firma macht jetzt einen Monat lang nichts anderes außer Sicherheit. Da wurde das besser. Dann haben sie angefangen Mitigations zu bauen, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen, Code-Outlets anzufangen usw. Bug Bounties immer gut, kann man mitnehmen. Also Full Disclosure machen, wenn der Hersteller unkooperativ ist, anfängt zu drohen, einfach eine Sicherheitslücke raushauen. Wenn es ein kooperativer Hersteller ist, Responsible Disclosure informieren, möglichst Bug Bounty abgreifen und den Ruhm und die Ehre gibt es hinterher immer noch.
Genau. Und wie gesagt, die Bug Bounties sind durchaus in einer Höhe, wo man sagen kann, da kann man, das ist schon mehr. Also das ist schon mehr als ein kleines Zubrot. Je nachdem, wie viele man findet und wie häufig man sie findet. Also da jetzt zu sagen, naja, ich muss da jetzt irgendwie einen Geheimdienst verticken, weil das ist so viel Arbeit gewesen, das zu finden, das hört man häufig als Erklärung. Und ich frag mich dann auch immer, wie die Leute gepolt sind. Okay, seid verantwortungsvoll mit Sicherheitslücken, falls ihr sie findet. Wir haben über den Umgang damit heute sehr viel gehört. Ihr könnt euch diese ganze Sendung auch nochmal als Podcast anhören, wenn ihr wollt. Er scheint im Laufe der Nacht auf fritz.de und dann irgendwann später auch auf chaosradio.ccc.de. Es will die Tradition, dass zum Schluss der Sendung noch ein paar Dinge angesagt werden. Insbesondere ist vom 13. bis 17. August ein Chaos Communication Camp. Wer möchte dazu noch etwas sagen?
Na wir gehen halt selten mitten in der Pampa im Ziegleipark Mildenberg. Das ist sozusagen das inverse Berlin, weil da hat sich an der Havel damals Ton abgelagert. Und dementsprechend wurden da Ziegeleien gebaut, wo Ziegel gebrannt wurden. Und jetzt gibt es da ganz ganz viele Seen, die zu gelaufenen Tage bauten für den Leben. Und das inverse Berlin, weil das wurde alles nach Berlin geschafft, nach oben gebaut. Also mitten in dieser historischen Industriearchitektur werden wir zelten. Wenig Strom, wenig Wasser, dafür viel Sonne haben und viel Spaß.
Und tatsächlich Internet. Und ganz kurz, wir haben auch... Aber warte mal, ihr fahrt dahin, ne? Ja. Aber ansonsten kann da keiner mehr hinfahren, weil die Tickets ausverkauft haben. Ja, aber die Leute, die keine Tickets haben, können auf jeden Fall zumindest die Vorträge, die dort laufen, über Streaming verfolgen. Das werden wir haben.
Ja, ganz wichtige Ansage. Es gibt morgen 22 Uhr mittel europäischer Sommerzeit nochmal einen Schwung Tickets, nämlich die Tickets, die die Leute nicht bezahlt haben, kommen nochmal in den Verkauf. Es gibt also nochmal eine Chance, hinzukommen.
Okay. Und die andere Nachricht, die es noch gab, war, es gibt einen kleinen Hacker Space in Berlin, der ein Problem hat. Genau, die Raumfahrt Agentur. Die wird nämlich aus verschiedenen Gründen, aus ihrer bisherigen Behausung rausgekantet und sucht jetzt dringend neue Flächen im Wedding. Und wer immer da gute Ideen hat, auf der Homepage der Raumfahrt Agentur findet sich da ein Aufruf. Wenn ihr da Ideen habt, wenn ihr wisst, ah Mensch, da gibt es eine schöne Fläche, die steht zur Verfügung, schaut euch doch mal um. Ansonsten sucht die Raumfahrt Agentur auch immer noch Unterstützer, die Mitglied werden wollen, um diesen Umzug zu stemmen. Das ist nämlich jetzt sehr, sehr kurzfristig alles. Und es wäre schade, wenn das da nicht weitergehen würde. Alles klar, dann wird es dir Bescheid. Ihr könnt euch gerne an die Leute vom Chaos Computer Club wenden, wenn euch etwas davon interessiert. Chaosradio.ccc.de, die Webseite zur Sendung. Ich danke den Anwesenden fürs Hiersein erklären und diskutieren, insbesondere Herrn Erdgeist. Dem Herrn Danimo. Und dem Herrn Andreas Boop. Immer wieder ein großes Vergnügen. Wir verabschieden uns von hier, übergeben dann an Flo Heiler, der im Nightfly euch wahrscheinlich elektronisch verstärkte Gitarrenmusik um die Ohren werfen wird. Ich gehe mal ganz stark davon aus. Mein Name ist Markus Richter, ich verabschiede mich auch. Mir bleibt nur noch eine Sache zu sagen. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.